So far we've discussed the structure and
purpose of standards.
The final dimension is technology.
And this is particularly
applicable to messaging standards,
where the messages must constructed
from data standards in a manner that can
be understood by the systems
that receive them.
We just discussed why.
Departments in a hospital that want to
share information with each other, so
for example, an order can flow
from the physician caring for
the patient to the lab, and
the result of the test can come back.
Messaging standards serve that purpose,
but now we're looking at
the technology in which those standards
are implemented and formatted.
Early messaging standards
were created using EDI/X12,
a standard that evolved in other
industries to automate business
processes such as ordering,
invoicing, and payment.
EDI/X12 was developed in the early
days of computing when memory and
storage were still dear.
So it is quite cryptic and
compact as you can see here.
Note that with some effort,
we can tell that this involves
a clinical lab and a glucose test.
But most of the details are not obvious.
In fact,
to understand each specific field,
typically requires a reference guide.
More recently, messaging and document
standards have been developed using XML,
a modern syntax that is verbose, but
has the advantages of being more human
readable and
easily rendered in a browser.
This is the same lab test
result we just looked at.
While it's still not easy to read,
we can much more easily tell
that it was a blood glucose level,
that its value was 182.
It says value right there.
And we can see the normal ranges for
the test are 70 to 105.